for tonight's relaunch at the beachfront
Salle's overdress sorry [ __ ] wrong
dressing I was really hoping Bryan would
step up as an owner given that I put
everything in place for him to succeed
in but his lack of focus has been really
worried that he's not fit to run this
place
come here let's go
your chef was shut down you didn't
realize so the first two salads for the
mayor had the wrong dressing on and wear
a dress I said it'd be taste that he
said no so he hasn't got your back
when's that pinning in a drop they're
gonna turn the corner we'll watch Ben
what if he doesn't come out of it switch
him and Joey will you how many
guacamoles you guys got out there okay
give me time on the math title please
Ben table 15 yeah the man's tight we
sold it
calamari Anna oh my did you see it
before he went I sure did I played it
everything
the mayor hasn't got a [ __ ] food
trying Brian
urgently commit so Ben's told me the
[ __ ] mayor's got their food and look
at the mayor's table there's nothing on
there look at me look look now we're
about to go down here and I'm gonna get
in my [ __ ] car
and I get to fight out there if you
don't get a grip because this is a
[ __ ] joke now you better get in there
and tell your detective champagne but
the mayor hasn't got their food and find
out where the [ __ ] it is been the mayor
has not gotten her food I'll put it in
the window where I'll make it right now
I'll make it right now let's try the
mayor's food
once I go
why is that
that is undercooked young lady come here
what's that chicken look like to you
black
thank you so dry
young lady how would you describe that
chicken very dry you know chef I thank
several 20 year old servings never
cooked even shoots pottery is dry and
you're saying is raw and you tell you
something and listen carefully
I'm Gary is that it's the worst thing
that a simple week is overcooked and dry
and then you tell me it's war
[Music]